guys met Ice spice yet I love ice spice
you guys met her couple times couple
times she seems sweet M sweet yeah I
like her uh I got to go try the ice Bice
drink from Dunkin Donuts she has her own
drink you didn't know that I saw that
and it would make sense someone would
give ice spice a drink like let me get a
ice spice on munchkins ice spice I think
she got her own pumpkin munchkins too I
think she got some Walky [__] yeah she
is she is Walky for
sure
right she is though she's very Walky
Walky she's super Walky she's walkie
yeah she's a Jabba you know I mean that
didn't work did it she's great I hope
you guys horse her for sure bro
what and by that I mean I hope you guys
do a song together you
bro that's exact opposite bro y' should
do a record with her when you play
around you [__] around ice
BR well y'all should do a record with
her y'all should do a record with her no
yeah we should yeah still what's he
saying anything else I should hit PR guy
because you know said PR
guy you guys this guy's doing David D's
job for him David D was like hey the
kids want to come up there again they're
going to be in town I'm like yeah let's
do it uh sure you didn't say like by the
way they were on Nikki's Queen radio by
the way they have the number one song in
New York by the way they have their own
language oh language Go
Crazy M O's gonna be in the video yo I
keep ask that bro Billy Dan's in uh and
Lil Fame mop is gonna be in the
video you trying bro where did you just
get y now y you guys are opening up for
sexy red in New York let's
go can't hit us [__] just want to
spice up the enemy and you guys and you
guys gave her grad great grades on her
Vine let's go you guys said great things
about her private parts it's a great
thing you guys gave them a you guys said
it looked great cuz it did good job guys
at that Viral so [__] right man sexy
red 41 on the same show in New York I'm
stage shaking my dreads free your baby
daddy man free your baby daddy all right
the date dad he was free he's not she
wants him she got a couple I I don't
believe so she's got the one who who she
was just fuing not her baby daddy a man
that's where the problem comes in I
still
sex I still love sexy right she's great
she's great she's the best she actually
uh when I interviewed her she got on to
mad real she jumped on top of this table
and um she had a photo shoot with her
money just by herself on the table right
here and I was like oh shoot with her
money she was like do you mind if I get
on top of the table and take some
pictures I do what you must sexy red do
what you got to do left you know what
I'm saying yo bring in the big bucks she
might I'm about to get on the table take
my pictures next shout out to sexy red
uh she's a real one appreciate y'all for
pulling up man looking forward to the EP
that's coming out in November
yo we outside your guy just confirmed
yes yes yo it's coming out in
November right around Thanksgiving
something for y'all to listen to when
you hanging out with your family on
Thanksgiving that new 41 EP is coming
out in November can't wait to hear it
appreciate y'all pulling up man man I
got some drugs for you y'all saw man
there's a bunch of pre-roll I mean there
there's no [__] you know chopped up
there's no spliffs in here spliff but
there is a a nice lovely King Palm giant
Leaf packed with some lovely premium
cannabis see that thing right there it's
like a [__] it's not a cigar it's
like it's like a jabawaki stum it's like
a [__] why is mad thick I don't know
cuz it's like mad thick cuz there's a
bunch of [__] weed in
there so where do I smoke from that's my
question well you you smoke from you
like that and then you smoke from here
yeah it's a filter I thought that was oh
my what the [__] is that it's a king
pal CBD yeah I mean it's weed it's CBD
no we're not never mind I was going to
say something that I would have got me
cancelled wait what you about to say
what I'm trying to say is we don't smoke
[__] CBD cuz we're real [__] men
over here okay about to say this is weed
you want some yeah I want it it's not a
spliff though I'm going roll into his
SPL not no don't roll smoke it like that
you don't got no cigar what cig at man
there's no grab in it there's no graba
in it bro it's a Lea nobody wants graba
in their [__] joints in La okay I'm
sorry well guess what I'm from New York
so I walk grabing my joint why terrible
this [__] is going to
float don't
touch so we're going to do PCP together
angel dust you want to float off of a
[__] spliff let's go we'll dip it in
that dust
I want to FL Method Man in 93 you know
who used to do a lot of angel dust with
Joe Buton shout out to Joe Buton he had
an addiction Joe Buton he's very opening
about it he has a song on his first
album called 10 minutes great song talks
about his PCP addiction what the [__]
angel dust like so what is you ever took
angel dust never you're lying I swear
you sound like you know a lot about
angel dust I know a lot about a lot of
drugs but I don't do them all buddy a
yeah we've already established this
earlier
you guys should try DMT the [__] is that
I heard of that that should take you
into another world it's a Spirit
Molecule man that [__] is De Ass Like
The Spirit Molecule you got a lighter yo
this [__] Rich yo shout out my son rich
man there what happened to the lighter I
gave y'all I should G did you guys
pocket the lighter I should is missing
oh no I see you broke my lighter you
took the lid off no way you're the
culprit you took the lighter the lid is
in the light the lid for the lighter is
right here torn
off you [__] lighter Thief what
happened you took it what happened to
the lighter it's in your pocket imagine
it's in your hoodie what it's in your
hoodie trying to get
you well appreciate y'all pulling up man
hey you guys should try some
DMT sexy Reds uh when's the show when's
the show of October October
October 17th and 18th you guys are
opening for sexy red never leave a a
lighter around Kyle he'll steal it and
break it
um uh you guys have the number five song
in New York City Nicki Minaj said hi to
you but not to them are you Dum n
definitely
said hey hey the turn around like Hey
Y'all doesn't count he got the
handshake all I was on her radio like
for me so did she shake your hand her
game would I had a blown liar I just
told you the conversation he had a
conversation she was not pressing I
could never be press [__] G [__] is you
talking
about no ain't going lie the Queen
the she
said she s there she said so she turned
around she like hey um what are you
doing what's your name he K Rich um yeah
I don't really want no phones behind me
you know people get weird and stuff he's
like yeah I'm sorry you had more of a
too Brad and say I'm sorry are youb are
you dumb I said I said feel me I
understand my fault gangster is
different my fault yeah it's a
sorry this that's literally I'm so you
you talk to her more than anybody you
just got a high T why did you talk he B
me talk I was really like she was like
I'm like yeah I S just one number one
I'm the reason she played B said you got
you got to play our [__] you gotta play
it like what's the number one song like
I saw her screenshot wow she played
it that's
sick legendary all right guys
well hopefully the song she gets on the
remix or something no yo nck stop that's
how label mate label mates stop Hing
label
mate isn't that mean Drake's your label
mate huh yeah there you guys I mean you
guys are on universal you guys got all
Republic's got all the [__] we all
winning man [__] the weekends you're
label mate post Malone H Malone Taylor
Swift your label mate is
yeah yeah that's pretty Grande too hey
she just had to pay her ex-husband $1.25
million in a divorce settlement are we
on a grande it was that serious let this
fellas be a lesson y'all marry up marry
up city boy up city boy up let's go all
right that's how we're ending the
interview city boy up city boy city boy
up man th000 points my S just city boy
up 1.25 million City boys up [__] off
of a [__] two-year marriage good for
him anyway with the marriage he did
shout out to let me not even well I'm
gonna let you get to your phone I
appreciate y'all pulling up man
boom what's going on man I want to shout
out to our family a hard Dean for
presenting to you another interview all
right there's another interview coming
tomorrow and the next day in the next
day shout out to Hardin though if you're
in Las Vegas man the number one
dispensary in the world there are family
there are brothers there are [__]
dogs over there man we love them they
always are taking care of us and they'll
take care of you if you go to Hardin in
Vegas let's say you're Landing in Vegas
you're going to go watch the Raiders
you're going to go watch a Vegas show
whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to harden they will get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg cev
show you say hey Harden I heard got
y'all on the bootleg C podcast they're
going to take care of y'all all right so
go follow him hardine Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
Las vegas.com what's up Harden